in the dawn age of Westeros before the
coming of man and the raising of castles
and cities there were only the children
of the forest little is known of them
now but it is said they were small in
stature dark and beautiful and no taller
than children when grown to manhood they
lived in the depths of the forests and
hidden villages chronics and caves they
hunted with weirwood bows and armed
themselves with blades of obsidian their
wise men were called Green says and the
possessed of powerful magic they
worshipped nameless faceless gods of the
forest stream and stone according to
legend it was they carved faces in the
great white trunks of the majestic
weirwoods their deep cut eyes were red
with SAP and ever watchful 12,000 years
ago the first man came from the Eastern
continent crossing a land bridge called
the arm of Dorne riding their great
horses and welding weapons of bronze
they cut down the children's forests and
where woods a terrible war raged between
the children in the first men the lasted
for centuries at long last the two races
sought an end to the years of horror and
bloodshed they met on a small Isle in
the center of a great lake called the
gods I it was there they forged the pact
the first man would be granted to men
you know with the coastland the
mountains the high plains in the bogs
but the deep forest would forever belong
to the children and no weirwood tree
would ever again fall to man's axe to
seal the pact before the gods the
children carved a face and everywhere
would tree on the island which came to
be known as the Isle of faces but the
pact could not withstand the coming of
the Andal a race of tall fair-haired
warriors they attacked with fire and
weapons of steel
slaughtering the children of the forest
wherever they could find burning out
their wayward groves hacking away at the
faces of the old gods and spreading
their own religion through the land
centuries have more followed and the
Andals conquered every Kingdom in West
all save one the north the kings of
winter were able to withstand the Andal
invasion the descendants of the first
men dwell where to this day and
continued to worship the old gods as for
the children of the forest those who
survived the slaughter were said to have
fled far north but have not been seen
again
most have seen their long dead but some
don't believe they ever existed they
live on only through song and legend and
in the faces of the weirwood trees